[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر
امام حبل المشنقه التفاصيل في العربيه 360
[موسيقى]
كما سببيه
الى اللقاء باستداره نحو الاسد
من السياسه الى الاقتصاد بوتن يتحدى الغرب
والكرملين لاوروبا ترقبوا ردا على تحديدا
فيما تستمر الاحتجاجات في ايران لم يبقى
لدى النظام سوى الاعدام وسيله لترهيب وردع
المحتشين وخلف ارقام المحكومين والمسجونين
وحتى الذين اعدمتهم طهران قصص وروايات
مجيد رضا
رهن ورده ثاني المحتاجين الذين اعدمتهم
ايران خلال اقل من ثلاثه اسابيع وشهر
رساله من امام حبل المشنقه الى شباب
الايرانيات الحيه للعديد من الشباب
الايرانيين الذين يعيشون في ظل الطبيه
كونان
بحق المتظاهرين قائلا ان ما تفعله الحكومه
الايرانيه غير مقبوله وليس له مبرره
الحكومه الايرانيه غير مقبول وليس له مبرر
من يطلق النار على شعبه الحكومه الايرانيه
تفعل ذلك ولهذا السبب سنواصل اتخاد مواقف
واضحه
وانضم الينا من اصل عضو منظمه حقوق
الانسان
الاحوزيه عمار كسائي اهلا بك سيد عمار
معنا الليله اذا نظام الايراني واصل
ترهيبه المتظاهرين من خلال الاعدام
والمزيد من الاعدامات في الطريق هكذا تقول
التقرير الاتيه من ايران ما الذي يريده
النظام وما الذي يعنيه هذا العدد الكبير
من الاعدامات لهؤلاء المتظاهرين
تحيه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام بطبيعه الحال
هذا مؤشر على ان النظام ذات يضيق ذرعا
بالمظاهرات ولا يستطيع احتواء الاحتجاجات
حيث اننا نشهد ان الاحتجاجات يوما بعد يوم
انطلقت قبل اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر هي تتوسع
وتشمل فئات مختلفه من المجتمع الايراني
ويلتحق بها فئات مختلفه من الاطباء من
الفنانين من لاعبي كره القدم من التلاميذ
من الطلاب من اساتذه الجامعه وهذا طبعا
يخيف النظام خاصه
في اي ثوره اخرى انه يلجا الى الاعدام
وسيله للترهيب وخاصه ان هذا النظام منذ
بدايه الثوره منذ الايام الاولى من انتصار
الثوره في عام سنه
1979 هو استخدم الاعدام كوسيدا للترهيب
والقضاء على
على منافسي او على
فرضت العديد من العقوبات الجديده على
ايران منذ يومين بريطانيا فرضت عقوبات
وامس طردت ايران من الهيئه الامميه لحقوق
المراه هل هو بين الغرب وايران تزداد
في ما يخص قضيه حقوق الانسان ولكننا لا
ننسى ان هذه العلاقات بين اوروبا وايران
او الدول الغربيه وايران لها وجهين يعني
الوجه الاول هو قضيه السياسه ومصالح هذه
الدول المتشابكه مع ايران خاصه
الحرف في القران هذه كلها خيوط متداخله
اما في قضيه حقوق الانسان طبعا بطبيعه
الحال ان هو ازداد بشكل كبير وايضا ااه
هل هو في حقل حقوق الانسان وقضيه احترام
حقوق الانسان والانتهاكات التي يقوم بها
النظام الايراني سوف تؤثر على
الجانب الاخر الجانب السياسي ايضا هو تجعل
هذه الدول الاوروبيه في الحقيقه ترقمها
لانه هناك ضغوط كبيره من الناس يطيح حقوق
الانسان من الناشطين الايرانيين من
السياسيين الايرانيين وحتى من السياسيين
في هذه الدول احزاب اليسا اليوم من العكار
فاعتقد ان هو نعم تزداد وتزداد عمقا
واتساعا وبسرعه كبيره ابقى معي السيد عمار
اذا مشاهدينا مع حجمي او حجم الاراء
وتكميم الافواه الى حجب من نوع اخر اعلن
عنه وزير الداخليه الايرانيه احمد وحيد
وهو حزب العالم الافتراضي من ايران بشكل
كامل وزير الداخليه الايرانيه عزى السبب
لمواجهه من وصفهم بالاعداء الذين يعملون
على صنع برامج لرفع الحجم بالاضافه الى
تشكيل لجنه للتحقيق في الاضطرابات الاخيره
بالبلاد وتقديم المتهمين للقضاء وكان
النظام الايراني قد نفذ اجراءات سابقه في
حجب تلغرام ومواقع التواصل بعد اندلاع
التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه ضد غلاء المعيشه
وتدني الاجوره بالمناسبات قبل شهرين تحدث
الماسك عن تزويد المحتاجين في ايران استنى
انت عبر تقنيه ستارلينج وناقش مع البيت
الابيض امكانيه اطلاق خدمات الاتصال
بواسطه منظومه اقمار ستارت
من جديد سيد عمار تسائي يعني تحجب المواقع
مواقع العالم الافتراضي بشكل كامل عن
الايرانيين وبالتالي هي محاولات ربما لعزل
الايرانيين خاصه المتظاهرين ولكن بالوقت
ذاته يعني نحن نعيش بعالم التكنولوجيا
والتقنيات الجديده
من من الايرانيين او من اي شخص يعني الان
لا يمتلك التقنيات لفك الحجب الفي بي ان
وبالتالي ما الذي تحاول هذه السلطات
القيام به وهل ستنجح بتخفيف زخم
الاحتجاجات
بطبيعه الحال هو حلم النظام منذ ان وصل
الى سده الحكم ان يعزل
الشارع الايراني والشعوب الايرانيه عن
العالم ولكن مع تطور التقنيه الان في
الظرف الراهن يعني اعتقد ان حجمه للانترنت
او حجمه لبعض
ولا يعطل يعني ربما نشاط المحتاجين او
المتظاهرين ولكنه لا يعطل ذلك بالامكانيه
الموجوده
تقنيه ستار لينك التي قيل ان ان اجهزه سوف
تتهرب الى داخل ايران كما تردد في الانباء
واعتقد ان هناك بعض من المحتجين يمتلكون
هذه الاجهزه وما باستطاعتهم ان يتواصلون
وخاصه ان التطور التقني المفترض التقنيه
قلبي فيها مواسائر التقنيه تجعل هذه مهمه
صعبه وخاصه ان ايران هو بلد مفتوح على
العالم ليس بلد منعزل كوريا الشماليه مثلا
ويستطيعون السيطره على ايران هو
القلب العالم
ولديه شعوب واعيه وشعوب يعني شعوب مثقفه
وهناك الكثير من المهندسين والتقنيين
الذين بامكان بامكانهم يواجهون هذا
الانعزال او العزله الا اذا ما فرضت من
قبل النظام شكرا جزيلا لك اذا السيد عمار
تسائي عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان الاحوسيه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه المكلف
بنيامين نتنياهو في مقابله مع العربيه ناس
انجلش ان الاحتجاجات في ايران تشكل خطرا
حقيقيا على نظام الايراني وبالحديث عن
المشروع النووي الايراني اكدانه اسرائيل
لديها القدره على منع ايران من امتلاك
قنبله النوويه وقال انها ستمنع طهران من
امتلاكي قنبله نوويه بلا اذن من واشنط
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر التطورات حادثه مقتل الجندي
الارلاندي في قوات اليونيفل العامله في
لبنان نقلت وكاله
التابعه لقوات اليونيفيل تعرضت لاصابه
بسبع طلقات جنوب لبنان واشار المصدر
القضائي الى ان احدى تلك الرصاصات اصابت
الجندي في الراس من الخلف مادى الى مقتله
[موسيقى]
استهداف ليس الاول
في جنوب لبنان في المعلومات المتداوله
اتجهت عبر طريق الاعتيادي في منطقه
عملياتها في جنوب لبنان
تعرضت الى حادث في بلده العاقبيه في ساعه
متاخره من ليل الاربعاء
كانت في طريقها الى مطار بيروت وعلامتها
جنديان للمفارقه كان عائدين الى ايرلندا
عاقبه لقيهما نبا وفاه افراد من اسرتهما
وهنا وقع الحادث والعمليه بانتظار
التحقيقات
احاطت بالاليه حشود وصفها وزير الدفاع
الايرلندي بالمعاديه وبداوا باطلاق النار
على جنود اليونيفيل ما تسبب بمقتل الجندي
ايلاندي واصابه ثلاثه رغم التفاصيل
القليله والمتضاربه وفقا اليونفيل فان
مصدرا قضائيا لبنانيا اشار الى معلومات
مهمه قد تقدم التحقيقا الذي تجريه
اليونيفيل مع الجيش اللبناني المصدر اكد
ان الاليه تتعرضت لسبع رصاصات اطلقت
باتجاه القوه التي تستقلها لكن النقطه
التي يجب التوقف عندها ان الجندي اصيب
برصاصه في الراس اي اشبه بعمليه تصفيه
مباشره
مفارقه اخرى حملتها الحادثه التي وقعت في
منطقه نفوذ حزب الله ان مسرح الجريمه يبعد
نحو خمسه كيلومترات عن العاقبيه موقع
اغتيال احد اشرس المعارضه الحزب لقمان
سليم في فبراير من العام 2021
عامل اضافي يعزز فرضيه تطورت حزب الله او
عناصر تابعه له وزير الخارجيه الايام
كوفاني قال ان ذلك لم يكن متوقعا نعم كانت
هناك توترات على الارض بين قوات حزب الله
واليونيفيل في الاشهر الاخيره الا ان ميسي
عن الحادثه وعادتها الى سكان المحليين
وصفه اياها بالحادث غير المقصود وان
الحسبه غير ضالع فيه لكن الشقوق القائمه
والاسئله كذلك في منطقه لا يتحرك او يتحرك
فيها شيء دون علم حزب الله او باعازه
[موسيقى]
في تركيا شهد محيط بلديه اسطنبول الكبرى
تظاهرات دعت اليه المعارضه رفضا لقرار سجن
رئيس بلديه المدينه المعارض اكرم امام
اوغلو ومنعه من العمل السياسي ويقود هذا
التجمع رؤساء سته احزاب معارضه كبيره في
تركيا من ابرازهم رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
ورئيسه حزب الخير القومي ورئيس حزب
الديمقراطيه والتقدم بالاضافه الى عشره
رؤساء بلديات ولايات كبرى في تركيا
وقال رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو
في كلمه له امام التجمع الاحتجاج لانصار
المعارضه قبل قليل ان السلطه الحاكمه في
تركيا لا تحترم القانون ولا الاخلاق وتسعى
لخنق اصوات النخبه
القانون ولا الاخلاق كما حاولت السلطه في
تركيا تعطيل عمل بلديه اسطنبول بعد خساره
الانتخابات واريد ان يشير الى انه تم
تغيير القاضي الذي كان موكلا بقضيتي لانهم
حسوا بانه لن يصدر حكما كما يرغبون تركيا
تقف على مفترق طرق بين من يقبل بالسياده
الوطنيه دون قيد او شرط وبين من لديهم
حساسيه من السياده الوطنيه
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول المحلل السياسي طه
عوده اوغلو اهلا بك سيد طه يعني
الاستئناف والطعن الذي ينوي رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول القيام به امام القضاء التركي حسب
معالمت بانه ياخذ وقتا احيانا من سنه الى
سنه ونصف بالتالي حسب معلوماتك بهذا الوقت
هل يمكنه الاستمرار بعمله السياسيه هل
يمكنه الترشح للانتخابات القادمه همم يعني
التي يعول عليها الكثيرون ويقولون بانها
ستكون حاسمه بتاريخ تركيا السياسيه
تحياتي لك فيها بدايه ولساده المشاهدين
قبل قليل بان هنا لم يتعلق بيئه القضاء
تستغرق وقتها طويلا وتعلمين ايضا بان وقت
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه هي في
صيف العامه المقبل يعني الاشهر قليله لهذه
الانتخابات ولكن كما ذكر محام
اكرم امام اوله بانهم سوف يقومون
بالاستئناف الطعم بهذا القرار الوالده
هناك همم ممكن ان يدخل وان يرشح نفسه لهذه
الانتخابات التي هي نعم حقيقه مفصليه
وحاسمه في تاريخ همم الحزب هنا الحزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم وايضا في
المعارضه التي هي تعول كثيرا لسحب بساط من
تحت اقدام رئيس اردوغان المتربي على
العاشق تقريبا العقدين همم
ما هذا القرار القضائي على ميزاج ال
الناخب التركي وهل كما يقال بانه هو لصالح
امام اوغلو يعني خدمه هذا القرار خدمه هو
اعاد الشعبيه له وللمعارضه التركيه
القرار هو شبيه بقرار الذي تعرض له الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عندما كان رئيسا
لبلديه اسطنبول في عام 90 وكانت هناك بين
قوسين يعني المظلوميه يتعرض لها اردوغان
ثم شاهدنا تبعنا كيف وصل الى سده الحكم في
عام 2002 ايضا حاليا امام اوغلو نفس
المكان يعني حتى في نفس المكان وهي بلديه
اسطنبول في منطقه الفاتح هنا يعني قبل
عقده من الزمن لانه شاهد امام اوه ايضا
نفسه يعني التهمه الموجه له هي ليستهما
الكبيره وخاصه انه هي ليست مقنعه للشارع
التركي ان كان همم المؤيد او حتى الشريحه
العاديه هنا داخل همم تركيا خاصه ممكن
يوصف هذا القرار بانه هو سياسي بالدرجه
الاولى همم يبدو ان اللقاء اصبح وشيكا بين
الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس السورير رئيس
النظام السوري همم بشار الاسد ما طبيعه
الاليه الثلاثيه التي تحدث عنها همم التي
تحدث عنها اردوغان ستجيبني على هذا السؤال
ولكن بعد الاستماع الى هذا التقرير ابقى
معي لو سمحت
خصم الامس حليف اليوم عباره قد تختصر
المشهد السياسي وربما الجغرافي المقبل على
الشمال السوري بعد ان كان الاسد صوره
الديكتاتوري الاكبر في نظر الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان بات مشروع تجاوز الخلافات
مطروحا اليوم على طاوله الحوار بواسطه
روسيه
او استداره حاده في نهج اردوغان الذي ذهب
الى حد اقتراح قمه ثلاثيه لتسريع المسار
الدبلوماسي مع دمشق فاثناء زياره الرئيس
التركي لتركمانستان ولقائه مع بوتين بدل
الاول باقتراح سلسله اجتماعات لحل عقده
الخلافات بين انقره ودمشق والتي تجاوز
عمرها العقد من الزمن
الثلاثي على مستوى اجهزه الاستخبارات اولا
ثم على مستوى وزراء الدفاع ثم وزراء
الخارجيه ثم القاده
مبادره اردوغان ترافقت بشروط اولها
الوساطه الروسيه مصرحا ان هناك
30 كم على طول الحدود المشتركه لكن وفق
تجارب المنطقه تاتي التسويات بثمن وباهض
احيانا مشروع التسويه الثلاثيه الذي
اقترحه الرئيس التركي قد يمر على جسرين
اساسيين القوه الكرديه شماليه سوريا التي
ترى ان من حقها حصد اثمان قتال داعش مع
القوات الامريكيه باداره ذاتيه تقيها ليس
فقط من الطموحات التركيه العابره للحدود
بل من عوده المحتمله لدمشق الى الحسكه
والتي قد تكون مكلفه عليها
جرون ثاني او ضحيه ثانيه الا وهي المعارضه
السوريه المقيمه في تركيا او ما تبقى منها
الى عمر العربيه
اذا نسيتها كنت سالتك عن
الاليات الثلاثيه بين روسيا تركيا وايضا
سوريا التي يطرحها اردوغان ما تفاصيلها
وايضا من الخاسر فيها من الخاسر من هذا
التقارب التركي السوري هل الاكراد سوريا
يعني انا بتصور اعتقد الحدث وهذه الخطوه
من قبل الرئيس اردوغان في متعلق بتسريع
الاليه ما بين انقره ودمشق وروسيا هي
تتزامن مع هناك وتيره
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
للتعاون مع قصدوا الرافد الامريكي الكبير
والواضح للعمليه العسكريه المرتقبه لاحظنا
خلال الفتره الاخيره ما نتحدث فقط خلال
شهر هناك تقارب تركي روسي غير مصبوغ قبل
اسبوع هناك مباحثات تركيه روسيه خرجت من
مقترحات اليوم الرئيس اردوغان يتحدث ايضا
عن اليه ويقول ان الرئيس بوتين هو نظر
اليها ايجابيا الرئيس اردوغان هو رسم
الخطوط العريضه لهذه الاليه بمعنى ان تكون
هناك لقاءات على مستوى الاستخبارات وزاره
الدفاع وزاره الخارجيه ومن ثم يكون هناك
لقاء الرؤساء الثلاثاء لذا اعتقد ان
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يريد ان يختصر
الوقت خاصه كما تابعنا خلال الفتره
الاخيره الماضيه كانت هناك نوع من
التصريحات صدرت من لنظام السوري فيما
يتعلق برفض اللقاء مع اردوغان فهو اردوغان
اراد ان يضع النقاط على الحروف وينهي هذا
الملف خاصه بانه هناك همم قاسم مشترك كما
تقول انقره مع النظام فيتعلق بمكافحه
الارهاب مكافحه الارهاب بالمفهومه التركي
وهو محاربه عناصر القوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه المدعومه الامريكيه
من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
اعلنا وزير البترول المصريه عن اكتشاف حقل
كبير للغاز في البحر المتوسط في وقتنا حمل
قرار الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
بترسيم الحدود البحريه الغربيه لبلاده
رسائل عده منها بالتاكيد على حق مصر
بالغاز الموجوده في البحر المتوسط واخرى
للتاكيد على قدرتها بحمايه مصالحها
التفاصيل في التقرير الثالث
توتر اقليمي بين عدد من دول البحر المتوسط
سببه حقوله غازي واكتشافات الطاقه
امر دفع الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
مؤخرا لاصدار قرار لترسيم الحدود البحريه
الغربيه للبلاد
فبحسب صحيفه الشرق الاوسط تضمن نص القرار
قوائم الاحداثيات الخاصه بالحدود
ويستهدف المحافظه على ثروات مصر وحقوقها
في غاز البحر المتوسط واكتشافات الجديده
لحقول الغاز
قرار يبدو فيه ان مصر ارادت ايصال رسائل
متعدده احداها قانونيه لتاكيد انه على
جميع الاطراف المعنيه احترام قواعد
القانون الدوليه في ظل توتر قائم بشان
عمليات التنقيب عن الغاز واخرى تحمل
خلفيات سياسيه وامنيه الهدف منها اظهار ان
مصر لن تنتظر احدا للدفاع عن مصالحها وح
حقوقها الى جانب ان الانقسام السياسيه في
ليبيا الذي بات بحسب مشرعين مصريين مساله
مهدده للامن القومي المصري
خصوصا مع اقدام حكومه عبد الحميد بيبا
منتهيه الولايه على توقيع اتفاقيات لترسيم
الحدود البحريه مع انقره اضافه لاتفاقيه
البيبه سبق لاردوغان والسراج توقيع
اتفاقيه امنيه مع رفض تركيا الاعتراف
باتفاقيه الامم المتحده لقانون البحار
لعام
وكان كل هذا كافيا لاقدام مصر على هذه
الخطوه من اجل حمايه حدودها ومواردها
بعد ان خطف من ليبيا وظهر في امريكا مخاوف
الليبيه من تكرار سيناري وابو عجيله مع
سنوسي 70
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
التي حدثت منذ ثلاثه عقود بين امريكا
وليبيا ثم اتفقت الدولتين على غلقها
نهائيا في عام 2008 بعد تسويه للخلافات
بينهما عادت الى الواجهه مره اخرى بسبب
صانع قنبله الذي خطف في ليبيا ثم ظهر في
امريكا انه المواطن الليبي ابو عجيله
مسعود المتهم بتفجير الطائر الامريكيه عام
1988 بالمناسبه هذه القضيه كانت قد طويت
في الماضي لكن اختفاء ابو عجله وظهوره في
واشنطن اعاده مخاوف لليبيين من تكرار هذا
السيناريو تحديدا مع قيادات بارزه بالنظام
السابق هذه التخوفات دفعت قبائل اقليم في
الزان لامهالي حكومه ادبيبه اثنين وسبعين
ساعه للافراجي عن مدير المخابرات في عهد
العقيده الراحل القذافي عبد الله سنوسي
[موسيقى]
علاقه وخاصه امراء السجون بان يحكم لغه
العقل ويستجيب الى هذا المطلب الشعبي اولا
والا سنضطر بيد سنضرب بيد من حديد غير
مباغين لتحقيق الهدف وفك اسر السجناء
ونعلنها الان بعد مده اقصاها 72 ساعه
وهناك سببان للافراج عن السنوسي الاول هو
الاتهامات الموجهه لحكومه الدبيبه بتسليم
ابو عجيله لوشنطن والثاني لانه من احد
الاسماء التي ذكرت في التحقيقات الامريكيه
البريطانيه المتعلقه بتفجير لوكاربي
ويعتقد ان له يدا في هذه الحادثه وبنبره
تحذيريه هددت قبائل الاقليم في الزنا
باتخاذ اجراءات تصعيديه في حال لم يتم فك
اسر اسنوني ورفاقه وقالت ان يدا من حديده
ستتحرك ما لم يتم الافراج عنه بعد انتهاء
المهله المحدده ياتي هذا التحرك القبلي
وسط مخاوف من ان يلقى السنوسي او يلقى نفس
المصير ويكون الهدف المقبل وهو الذي ذكر
اسمه كما ذكرنا في التحقيقات المرتبطه
بالحادثه
[موسيقى]
الرهان وعلى انهيار اقتصاد روسيا لم ينجح
والعقوبات الاوروبيه حضرت بهذه الدول بحسب
الرئيس الروسي
على روسيا تسببت بتضخم قياسيه في الدول
الاوروبيه وان اقتصاد بلاده صامد على عكس
ما تمنى الغرب روبل تحول الى احدى اقوى
العملات في العالم هذا العام خلال اجتماع
مجلس التنميه الاستراتيجيه والمشاريع
الوطنيه الروسيه اضافه بوتن ان الغرب شلنا
عقوبات عدوانيه غير مسبوقه ضد روسيا
ومحاوله سرقه احتياطات موسكو من العملات
الاجنبيه واعتبر الرئيس الروسي ان السلطات
ورجال الاعمال في روسيا عملوا بطريقه
مركزه ومهنيه وان المواطنين اظهروا تضامنا
ومسؤوليه مجمل المعطيات بحسب بوتن ادت الى
توقعات داخليه منخفاض الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي باثنين ونصف في المئه وليس كما
توقعت مؤس الغربيه ان يصل الانخفاض الى
20%
وخلافا لما يحدث في دول اخرى اشار الرئيس
الروسي الى ان مستوى الاسعار في السوق
الروسيه بقي دون تغيير تقريبا منذ مايو
بينما ترزح دول اخرى تحت معدلات تضخم
مرتفعه جدا بحسب قوله
[موسيقى]
في قطاع الطاقه قال الكلام لان الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتان يعتزموا توقيع مرسوم خلال
ايام يحدد رد روسيا على فرض الغرب لسقف
على سعر صادرات النفط الروسيه حتى الان لا
تزال تبعات قرار دول مجموعه السبع بتحديد
سعر النفط الروسي ب 60 دولارا للبرميل غير
واضحه اما روسيا فقد اكدت ان قرار الحظر
وتحديد الاسعار سيدفع البرميل الى مستويات
مرتفعه مجددا لانه سيصيب الصناعه بالخلل
لكن ما هي خيارات موسكو للرد خبراء
نفترقعوا ان احد الخيارات يتمثل في تحويل
مبيعات النفط الخام التي كانت موجهه الى
اوروبا نحو الشرق وبخاصه الى الهند والصين
اللتين ربما تقومان ببيع النفط الروسي الى
اوروبا عبر قنوات ثالثه وباسعار مرتفعه
خيار اخر وهو ان تشتري شركات طاقه عالميه
الخمر الروسيه وان تنقله من ناق روسيه الى
اخرى في اعالي البحار لبيعه في الاسواق
الاوروبيه على انه نفت من بلد ثالث اما
الخيار الثالث فهو تخفيض انتاج النفط
وبالتالي رفع الاسعار نتيجه زياده الطلبيه
في السوق
[موسيقى]
الباحث الاقتصادي الدكتور دانيال ملحم
اهلا بك دكتور دانيال يعني استمعنا الى
خيارات يمكن ان تكون رد روسي على القرار
الغربي ولكن وكاله بلومبرج العالميه تحدثت
امس مع مصادر روسيه خاصه
وقالت بانه الاجراءات الروسيه لن تكون
قاسيه كثيرا همم بل انه القرار الروسي لن
يمنع دول معينه من شراء النفط النفط
الروسي لكنه سيحضر المبيعات على عقد ينص
على وضع حد اقصى للسعر يعني
الشرط الاهم بالنسبه له انه العقود همم ان
لا تنص على وضع السقف اي من تلك الخيارات
تراها اقرب للمنطق والى تفكير الروس
تحيه لك سيدتي والمشاهدين الكرام اعتقد
انه الحل يمكن ان يكون مزيج من من كافه
الحلول ولكن النظر الى هذه الحلول
المطروحه اليوم امام على الطاوله نرى ان
هناك بعض الخيارات سوف تؤدي الى مزيد من
الخسائر لروسيه اكثر من الاخرين لذلك هنا
كل خيار يكون محدود بما كان ما ويكون له
ربحيه في مكان ما ولكن لا يوجد خيار واحد
يمكن تطبيقه ويمكن المشي فيه مثلا هناك
بعض الخيرات التي تقول ان من ان النفط
الروسي سوف يجد له بدائل في دول في دول
جنوب شرق اسيا اعتقد ان احنا نتكلم عن
المليونير برميل يوميا وهذي كميه هائله
جدا لن يجد همم عمليا اسواق في جنوب شرق
اسيا خصوصا الصين هو تعاني اليوم تعاني من
ضعف الطلبه الداخلي تعاني في الطعام في
الاستهلاك على الاقتصاد الاقتصاد الصيني
سوف يعادل خلال عقد المقبل وبالتالي النمو
المتوقع لهذا الصين لن يتخطت ليله الاربع
بالمئه همم الهند
يعني سوف تتحول اكثر فاكثر لاستخدامات
الاستخدامات الفحم الفحم الحجري اضافه
لذلك يمكن ان تستورد ال- ال- النفط الروسي
وتبيعه صحيح وهذا ما يحدث الان الى اوروبا
او للولايات المتحده وغيرها الامر الثاني
انه يتعلق انه عمليا ما هي الناقلات التي
تنقل تنقل هذا النفط الروسي الى هذه الدول
اعتقد عمليا ان هناك مجموعه من الحلول وكل
الحل يصد ثغره معينه ولكن لا يوجد حل حل
بالشكل الكامل ولكن الحل للمؤذي اكثر هو
تخفيض الانتاج اذا كان الرئيس الروسي يهدد
بتقويه الانتاج فهذا يتوقف على العرض
والطلب العالم المستقبلي بال22 ل 2024 من
خلال قرارات المركزيه لمصرف المركزيه
اليوم نحن نرى انه سوف ندخل في ركوب كبير
بال 2023 في العالم وهذا عمليا لن يساعد
عمليا الرئيس الروسي بخفض الانتاج لذلك
خفض الانتاج في دوله ظروف الركود العالمي
سوف يرتد الان على روسيه
يعني بما يخص رفع الفيدراليه الامريكي
للفائده همم طبعا دول الخليج تسارع الى
رفع تلك الفائده همم
وارتباطها بشكل مباشر بالدولار الامريكي
همم حتى الان تاثير رفع اسعار الفائده هنا
لا يزال محدودا هل سيبقى كذلك في المستقبل
في الاسواق اكثر ما هي ال- ال- الرفع
الفائده الرفع الفائده هي الاداه التي
تتحكم بالشروط الاميريه بالاسواق ونتكلم
بالشروق الالمانيه في الاسواق هي عمليا
الكتله النقديه التي تسمى بالام 2
وبالتالي هذا هو هذا هو لب همم لب القضيه
هي كيف ستتحرك عمليا همم كفى تتحرك او
عمليه تتغير هيكليه هذه الكتله النقديه هل
ستبقى موجوده داخل البنوكها وتتهم تتحول
عمليا الى الى الى
اسواق السندات هذا كله عمليا مطروح الان
على الطاوله اذا كنت سيده تعني فيما يخص
المنطقه الخليج العربي او الدول العربيه
العربيه المرتبطه اقتصاديتها بالدولار
بشكل كبير لا اعتقد انه سوف تتاثر بشكل
كبير على اعتبار ان اغلب هذه الدول هي
تملك سياسات ماليه توسعيه وهناك استثمار
الضخمه وبالتالي لن تؤثر بشكل كبير او
بالمدى المندور على المدى القصير طالما
انها السياسات الماليه موا الى السياسه
النقديه وبالتالي لن تتاثر عمليا السيوله
النقيه داخل هذه الاسواق ان ما في متعلق
في الاسواق الاخرى نعم سوف يكون هناك بما
يسمى همم ريسك دوليكيتيه او عمليا مخاطر
السيوله وسوف يكون هناك ثمن لهذه السيوله
في الاسواق العالميه للان ال- ال- الخطر
محدود على مدى القصير في دول الخليج ام
اذا تطورت الامور ودخلنا في ركوب وانخفضت
اسعار النفض اعتقد انه يمكن ان تغير هذه
الدول من استراتيجيته على المدى الطويل
ويمكن ان ينخفض الاستثمار
قد حدث فعلا مع قرار الاحتياطي الفدرالي
برفع اسعار الفائده ب 50 نقطه اساس الى
نطاق يتراوح بين اربعه فاصل 25% واربعه
فاصل خمسه بالمئه هذه النسبه همم مشاهدينا
تمثل اعلى مستوى في 15 عاما ورغم تباطئ
وتيره رفع الفائده بعد السلسله من
الزيادات المتتاليه بخمس وسبعين نقطه اساس
الا انا رئيس الفيدرالي حافظ على نبته
الحذره مؤكدا انه لا يزال هناك حاجه
لمزيدا من العمل
وبحسب ما يعرف بالضبط
همم توقعات الفرديه لاعضاء الفدرالي بخصوص
الفوائد من المرجح ان ترتفع الفائده
باجماله 75 نقطه اساس بنهايه العام المقبل
ليصله نطاقها المستهدف الى 5.1% لتعود
فائده لا لا انخفاض الى
4.1% في 2024
و3.1 في عام 2025 على الصعيد التضخم يتوقع
1000درالي بقائه فوق معدل اثنين في المئه
المستهدف على الاقل حتى نهايه عام 2025
كما توقع الفيدرالي ان يرتفع متوسط معدل
البطاله الى 4.6% خلال العام المقبل من
ثلاثه فاصل سبعه بالمئه النسبه الحاليه
وهي زياده تتجاوز المستوى المرتبط تاريخيا
بالركود اشار 1000 دره لي الا ان الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي قد ينمو صفر فاصل خمسه
بالمئه فقط في عام 2023 وهي النسبه ذاتها
التي تم توقعها للعام الحالي قبل ان يرتفع
النمو الى واحد فاصل سته بالمئه في عام
و1.8% في عام 2025
اعتدى يوسف
قررت اللجنه رفع اسعار الفائده بواقع نصف
في المئه الى نطاق يتراوح بين اربع وربع و
4.5% برنامج تخفيض الميزانيه العموميه
سيستمر في العمل كما هو مخطط له قمنا برفع
اسعار الفائده بنسبه 4:15 منذ بدايه هذا
العامه وما زال امامنا بعض الطريق سنقطعه
في رفع اسعار الفائده الى ان نصل الى
المستهدفاتنا للتضخم عند اثنين في المئه
نصف نقطه مئويه نظرا لارتباط معظم عملات
المنطقه بالدولار ولا زال تاثير رفع اسعار
الفائده بين دول الخليج المصدره للنفط في
عام 2022 محدودا حتى الان رغم ان المحللين
يتوقعون ان يكون التاثير واضحا في
المستقبل وقال جرام باول رئيس الاحتياطي
لان البنك المركزي الامريكي سيتمنى المزي
من الرفع في سعر الفائده في عام 2023 رغم
انزلاق الاقتصاد الامريكي نحو ركود محتمل
وبرر ذلك بان الاقتصاد سيتكبد ثمنا باهظا
اكثر اذا لم يكبح المركزي التضخم بقوه
مؤكدا ان البنك لا يفكر في اي تغيير لهدف
التضخم البالغ اثنين في المئه ولا ينوي
التفكير في القيام بذلك مستقبلا مشيرا الى
انه من السابق لاواني الحديث عن خفض البنك
لاسعار الفائده
فوق شويه
تركيزنا في الحقيقه ينصب الان على تحويل
موقف سياستنا الى موقف ينطوي على تشديد
كفن لضمان عوده التضخم الى اهدافنا
البالغه اثنين بالمئه بمرور الوقت ولا
يتعلق الامر بتخفيضات اسعار الفائده
[موسيقى]
اضراب هو الاكبر في تاريخ النظام الصحه
الحكومي في بريطانيا استمر لمده يومين
والمطالب واحده تحسين ظروف العمل ورفع
الاجور ودعم القطاع الاضراب ادى الى الغاء
واعاده جدوله العديد من مواعيد المرضى
والعمليات لنحو 70,000 شخص بحسب وزيره
الصحه
في شهر تاريخي للاضرابات في بريطانيا يبدا
الاضراب الاكثر انذارا بالخطر والاكثر
اثاره لقلق المرضى وعائلاتهم يضربوا عشرات
الالاف من الممرضين في انجلترا ووينز
وايلاند الشماليه في احتجاج هو الاكبر في
تاريخ قطاع الصحه البريطاني بعد رفض
الحكومه مطالب الممرضين بزياده رواتبهم
بنسبه 19% وهي نسبه تعتبرها الحكومه اعلى
من قدره تحملها
وصفها الممرضون بالمهينه بحقهم اعتبار
انهم اكثر الموظفين التضررا خلال الرائحه
كورونا فيما توعد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي سوناك بفرض قوانين جديده للحد من
الاضطرابات وضمان الحد الادنى من مستويات
الخدمه
يوم ما اسوي هكذا وصف العديد الحاله التي
وصلت اليها بريطانيا التي تعاني من اوضاع
المعيشيه سيئه يشعر بها العديد من
المقيمين والعاملينا هنا
اضراب باستخفاف ولاسيما الممرضين الممرضين
على الخط الامامي طوال الوقت
ليس كافيا وانهم بحاجه الى القيام بشيء
اكثر جوهريا
نحن مرهقون للغايه ونعاني من نقص في عدد
الموظفين منذ سنوات عديده وبشكل عام منذ
كبد
فنحو 50,000 وظيفه شاغره يعاني من نقصها
قطاع التمريض ما يعني تكدس اعداد المرضى
على لوائح الانتظار الذين وصلت اعدادهم
الى سبعه ملايين ومن المتوقع ان تطول
اللائحه من لندن عروب عبد الحق العربي
الى صوره اليوم فبيروح الرياضيه عاليه
عاده الخصمان كيليان مبابي واشرف حكيمي
ليكون صديقين عقبه صافره نهايه مباراه
المغرب
وفرنسا الصداقه القويه التي تجمع مبابي
وحكيمي كانت مسيطره على الاجواء تعانق
اللاعبان وتبادل القمصان ليحتفل بابي
بقميص اشرف حكيمي
تصريح اليوم مشاهدينا لمدرب المنتخب
المغربي وليد الركراكي الذي وفي اول تصريح
له عقبه مباراه المغرب مع فرنسا عبر عن
فخره بلاعبيها عقب الخساره في نصف نهائي
كاس العالم واضاف المهم اننا قدمنا صوره
جيده وان الكره في المغرب ليست ببعيده عن
اعلى المستويات